in the beginning
storks delivered babies it wasn't always
easy no matter how tough or impossible
or brutal or inhumane more savage we
would triumph over adversity thank
goodness we don't do that anymore
now storks deliver packages per quarter
store.com there's one less baby to
deliver this is a family that never got
the baby they asked for if this baby
finds their families then maybe I can
find mine all right let's do it let me
show you how to fly that hello I'm a
bird I'm pretty sure I know how to
you see what yep I peed in the seat we
were falling my old nemesis
I built my plaintiff I my parents you'll
find your family
don't worry honey everything's gonna be
just fine
for ball this happening
sorry never seen it before nature's just
taste like flour okay stand aside
are you in love I am in luck are you in
love I'm in love too angry I agree I
agree I agree it's like your best friend
that lived together mom dad I've decided
I want a baby brother here store
delivery service outside really